Remember that the David Pakman show is mostly
funded by members who sign up at join Pacman
dot com.
It's cheap, it's quick, it's easy, and you
get access to the world famous award winning
bonus show.
Okay.
Yeah.
I mean, there are awards we give out, but
still awards nonetheless.
A grab a membership at join Pacman dot com
to day.
Our primary source of revenue.
It is really not a good week for Donald Trump.
The UK's Channel four has released a bombshell
investigation, exposing that in 2016, the
Trump campaign actually had a specific strategy
to prevent black people from voting.
Now, remember that publicly in 2016, Trump
was sort of paying lip service to how much
he loves black people.
Whereas my African-American, he said a couple
times during rallies saying he's gonna do
so well with black voters.
But privately, they knew that black voters
were going to go overwhelmingly for Hillary
Clinton.
And rather than trying to convince black voters
to vote for Trump, what they did was to try
to keep black voters from voting altogether.
And the Channel four investigation really
well done exposes exactly how they did this.
And there's really a lot to go through here.
This was done through social media targeting
with very detailed analytics.
The Trump campaign had three and a half million
black Americans in their database of about
200 million voters, and they categorized those
black Americans overwhelmingly under what
was called a deterrence campaign, meaning
deter folks from voting.
That's what the deterrence category was, people
that the campaign hopes do not vote.
So, for example, in Georgia, despite black
voters, Konsta black black Americans making
up 32 percent of the Georgia population, they
were 61 percent of the deterrence category
in North Carolina.
Black people are 22 percent of the population,
but they were 46 percent of the deterrence
category.
Similar numbers in Wisconsin and in other
places.
There were also Hispanic and Asian-Americans
disproportionately in these deterrence campaigns.
And meanwhile, the get out the vote campaigns
were disproportionately white voters.
And indeed, we can't say it was specifically
because of this, but certainly it played a
role.
Black turnout fell in 2016 for the first time
in 20 years.
The way they worked these campaigns included,
for example, using highly produced videos
containing clips of Hillary.
Hillary Clinton using the term super predator
and showing those to the deterrence group
along with other tactics.
And again, the idea being dissuade black voters
from voting at all.
They know that Trump's not going to do well
with the black voters.
Try to get black voters to say, and I don't
know that I want to go out and vote for Hillary
and try to simply keep them home.
So there are a few things to discuss here.
First of all, it's shocking to see it done
so brazenly, but it makes sense that the Trump
campaign would try to deter black people from
voting.
Let's just be very, very real here.
The Trump campaign didn't make sense for black
voters or Latino voters or others because
their policies were not going to be good for
those groups, plain and simple.
So Hillary Clinton won the black vote 89 to
eight in 2016.
And Donald Trump's campaign identified that
if you if you can keep a group that is going
to skew so heavily in favor of Hillary Clinton
at home, it's good for you.
So it's not surprising from a mathematical
perspective.
If you were Trump's campaign publicly, of
course, you say yes, black Americans vote
for Trump.
We're going to make it great for everybody.
It's gonna be fantastic.
Privately, you know, they're not going to
vote for you and you're better off just trying
to keep them home.
So it is a rational strategy given the numbers
and the data.
Second, remember that the social media platforms
are a huge part of this.
Facebook allowed this to be done.
And indeed, Channel four, as part of their
investigation, went to Facebook and said,
Farai, you know, do you have a comment on
this?
And Facebook said, listen, we've changed things
since 2016, which is a way of saying, yeah,
it happened in 2016 and we allowed it to happen.
They said we now have 35000 people working
to ensure the integrity of our platform.
We now have rules that prohibit campaigns
that are trying to suppress the vote.
So they are conceding that this this happened
and that this took place.
So the platforms that allow this stuff are
a big part of the story.
In addition to a Republican platform that
is completely unappealing to black voters
and black.
Voters accurately determine that.
But then there's a third part, which is Trump's
doing this again this year.
It's not being done in the exact same way.
But with voter purges in disproportionately
black areas, with fear campaigns, with intimidation
tactics, talking about, you know, Democrat
run urban areas and cities are going to have
police on Election Day and we're going to
be monitoring and blah, blah, blah.
The goal is the same, although the tactics
are different.
We can't let them win with it.
I predict very high turnout from black voters
this time around.
Whether that will lead to a Joe Biden electoral
victory.
Well, we've got to go out and vote.
You know that